So, thanks Lauren. So, you know, another way in which we express emotion is
through our voice. As it turns out, our voice is harder to control than our
face. People can lie with their face more easily, because it's under voluntary
control. But our voice is regulated by the autonomic nervous system. And
remember the autonomic nervous system, we don't control. So, it's harder to
manipulate. And for instance, we also have pitch changes with our voice. And
pitch changes might happen when we have voice cracks, when we're nervous or
when we cry. So, two good examples of recognize an emotion in the voice, are
with young children, and when people are speaking foreign languages. So, for
instance, in young children. They may not understand the words, but they
clearly understand the emotional tone. So, for instance, if I parent says, oh,
isn't that sweet versus no. The child may not understand those words, but
clearly understands the emotional tone.